one core trait in every dog is its ever
forgiving nature that's probably the
most valuable thing in a dog and it's
also its biggest pitfall because we have
dogs here who've been horribly hurt by
human beings and yet all they want to do
is find somebody else to love
[Music]
around the world strays mutts and street
dogs are victims of stigma
in costa rica leah battle is trying to
change that story she runs the
territorio de cuates it's a lush haven
for stray dogs to either be adopted or
to live out the rest of their days
territory is stands for land of the
month
my name's leah battle better known as
crazy dog lady i guess i started
territorios aguatis partly because i've
always loved animals all animals
but it wasn't in my plans it wasn't like
i set out to do this
the need for this i think all over the
world is because there's a huge stigma
around a dog that doesn't have a breed
they'll let mutts wander on the streets
or they'll actually toss them on the
streets because they're not breed dogs
the solution isn't euthanizing a dog the
solution is make sure it's not born in
the first place
once it's here do something good for it
find a home or if not at least offer him
a place where he can be in peace and
happy
keeping territorial up and running is no
easy feat they eat 500 a day in food
alone leah has to work a full-time job
to keep all the dogs fed and healthy
territorio
stays about partly through
miracles i think
keeping this afloat is a huge task
it's a labor of love
you can't
pay someone to care for an animal truly
to remember their names to be gentle to
them while this place is a dog heaven
nothing beats getting adopted by a
loving family i'd say it's like kids at
kindergarten they love their friends at
school but oh they all want to go home
to mom and dad
you can't really call me a crazy cat
lady i'm i'm obsessive i would rather
have 800 cats than another man i don't
need a man in my life
been there done that bought the t-shirt
new get it get it kitty
this is called the cat house on the
kings
it's a 12 acre no cage no kill sanctuary
rescue adoption center and we also do a
lot of space and neuters
oh come here cricket
[Music]
we have close to 800 adults and 300
kittens on the property as we speak
it wasn't like i planned hey i think
i'll have a thousand cats
what a novel idea it wasn't like that i
thought there's always room for more
they're gonna kill this one we have way
too many cats
so this this was my house
you can see that it's an extremely large
house
so you had to give up your home for
these cats i tried for about 16 years to
make it work but it wasn't okay having
60 something in my bedroom one night
they threw up in my ear
and that was when i moved all 4 200
square feet is theirs that's why we call
it the cat house
[Music]
we have saved over 28 000 cats
in 24 years
we have
a staff now of about 45. you have to be
very on top of the job
because
you have a lot of cats that you're
responsible for no point in rescuing
them and taking them in if you can't
take care of them you know this is not
normal
people after a while would say well you
know i think i've done this enough i
think i'll go have a life now i think
i'll go travel nope not me
daphne look this way
come on i want you to be on tv
[Applause]
[Music]
in chennai india there's a tiny camera
repair shop run by a man named joseph
cecar and i had a sega under the police
worldwide on the board
got his nickname because every day he
feeds thousands of hungry parakeets on
the roof of his home
[Music]
the 2006 tsunami that hit southeast asia
flooded parts of india and displaced
thousands of birds
seikar noticed a pair of parakeets
outside of his home and set some rice
out for them
then more started to show up
and well
in the front door
[Music]
feeding eight thousand parakeets twice a
day is a great expense
sakhar spends about 40 percent of the
money he makes from repairing cameras
buying food for the birds
[Music]
but for the birdman of chennai there is
more to life than money
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my name is
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
animals
[Music]
okanoshima island is a short 12-minute
ferry ride from hiroshima region of
japan
while the sandy and palm line beaches
are perfect for holidaymakers the island
draws crowds for a different reason
rabbits
lots of them
and how they got there is a mystery
[Music]
between 1929 and 1945 the japanese army
secretly produced over 6 000 tons of
poison gas on okanoshima island some
believe the current rabbits are
descendants of those brought to the
island to test the gas but the current
director of the poison gas museum
insists these bunnies have nothing to do
with those from the world war ii era
so where do they come from
[Music]
one theory
[Music]
so those rabbits were released and with
no real predators they bred like
well
like rabbits
and yet another theory
is
either way this new generation of feral
rabbits has the run of the land they're
creating a new story separate from the
sordid past of okonoshima island an
island once known for death is now known
for possibly the cutest thing ever
bunnies
[Music]
house
okay before we go any further this is a
swiftly
it's a small brown and black bird whose
nest are a highly sought after delicacy
here in the philippines people eat them
in a soup called
well bird's nest soup
typically these nests are found high
high up on cliffs super hard to get to
taco
bell
so when these birds moved in eddie
didn't kick them out instead he gave
them half his home
[Music]
20 minutes
so they boil it add some veggies a bit
of meat and voila
bird's nest
[Music]
[Music]
understandably so some people they just
can't appreciate the smell of 80 000
birds worth of droppings
but eddie and the swiftlets have an
arrangement
of
foreign
[Music]
you